we're going to start today with two
bloodbaths one that is taking place and
one that could take place a few months
from now the first one is a bloodbath in
the Fox news ratings and I know that
this brings such great pleasure to so
many in my audience some feel bad but
the most important thing is that this is
a bloodbath that is taking place without
any government overreach without any
suppression of anybody's speech or
anything of the sort it is a
self-inflicted bloodbath for Fox News
Fox News has lost half of its audience
since firing Tucker Carlson during that
time slot and there's a lot of different
interesting layers to this and many many
of you have been writing is this the end
of Fox News well no it's not the end of
Fox News but is this the end of Fox News
as we knew it well that's a different
question and we still have to wait and
see
the outcomes of multiple additional
lawsuits that still remain in play even
though the Dominion lawsuit has been
settled for 787 and a half million
dollars uh Salon article it's a
bloodbath Fox News loses more than half
of audience after axing Tucker Carlson
it's not just Tucker's slot writes the
article Sean Hannity and Laura
ingraham's ratings are falling too
hundreds of thousands of Fox News
viewers have switched off the channel
after the network fired top Prime Time
host Tucker Carlson last Monday
substitute host Brian Kilmeade garnered
1.3 million audience members during that
8 pm time slot down
from the 3.05 million viewers who tuned
in to watch Carlson last Wednesday
according to Nielsen ratings The Dip
allowed msnbc's Chris Hayes to overtake
Fox and ratings a popularity contest
that Carlson used to dominate the
conservative host had an average
audience of 3.03 million people for all
of 2022 it was the second most popular
program on cable after Fox's V it is
stunning to me that foxes the five is a
popular show it's almost completely
unintelligible but I guess it doesn't
really matter when you're talking about
Fox News okay we'll get back to that one
approach for comment Fox sent a
statement saying for 21 years it's been
the most watched cable network and it
has a team that's quote trusted more by
viewers than any other news source
a media reporter Brian stelter noted in
a tweet that Fox's audience ratings
plummeted from 2.65 million watching
Carlson's final show to 2.59 Monday 1.7
Million Tuesday 1.3 million Wednesday
what's fascinating about that is that
the relatively high ratings on Monday
which was Tucker's first show gone in
other words Brian kilmeade's first show
is the temporary host there
um there was a lot of curiosity sort of
like a rubber necking how bad is it
going to be it turns out it's really bad
I mean kill meat is not only meaningless
to listen to but also extraordinarily
unentertaining and uncharismatic and
then a lot of people said well if this
is the replacement then I'm out
um and uh it sort of has gotten worse
from there so let's talk about this in a
few different contexts first of all this
isn't one of those oh there's dirty
tricks there's free speech suppression
and people are being uh limited by the
woke mob or whatever else the case may
be as we have now established ad nauseum
Tucker Carlson had good ratings but was
a huge legal risk for Fox and remember
Fox is is unique as a Cable News Network
in that it Garners the vast majority of
its revenues from fees that any of us
who have cable pay
even though I don't watch Fox I have
cable so I can watch the sports and
things like that and
um a couple bucks I guess somewhere
between two and four dollars of my cable
subscription goes to Fox News even
though I don't watch Fox News that makes
Fox different than many of these other
channels in that the other channels
disproportionately rely on ad Revenue so
the the issue with Tucker was not an
issue of
um audience the issue was that he was a
huge legal risk and so what fox decided
to do is to fire Tucker Carlson and I've
already told you the reasons why
Tucker's program partially responsible
for disseminating the allegedly
defamatory content that led to the 787
million dollar settlement with Dominion
responsible to some degree for the
content that led to the ongoing lawsuit
from smartmatic you have a former
staffer of Tucker Carlsons who has filed
a lawsuit for alleged discrimination and
misogyny sexism all sorts of that's a
problem and then you potentially have
another forthcoming lawsuit from Ray
Epps who says that Tucker has made his
life miserable by uh playing up a
conspiracy conspiracy theory in which
Ray Epps is some kind of FBI agent or
actor
instigating the January 6 right so fox
said this is a huge legal headache maybe
one of the ways we can mitigate the
damages we're going to end up having to
pay is by saying we've taken care of
what was one of the problems that caused
these issues for us in the first place
fine Fox News did that no one converts
them into doing that the viewers are mad
and they don't like Brian Kilmeade and
everybody is getting to make their own
decisions nobody's being coerced here
now what's the Counterpoint to all of
this while it's nice to see Fox
suffering not because we want to see
people go hungry or whatever it's nice
to see Fox suffering because they put
out such terrible propaganda that is
actively damaging and corrosive to
American democracy and thinking that
it's good that bad content suffer
it's alarming to see that a bunch of
Fox's audience is not going to say hey
you know what I'm going to get my news
from the AP and Reuters and for
commentary listen to you know I don't
know something much more moderate some
editorial page or whatever the case may
be a lot of the folks furiously tuning
out of Fox News May well end up on even
more extreme unhinged media Outlets like
Newsmax or oan or who the hell knows
what and the United States has a major
problem with people have gotten hooked
on this sort of thing as we've talked
before Fox News in some senses over the
last two years since the 2020 election
became a victim of the monster it
created it knew we now know from text
messages that they were perpetuating
lies about the 2020 election they knew
Trump didn't really win they knew that a
van with sandwiches wasn't really proof
that Trump actually won Michigan or they
knew it but they also knew Their
audience which they've created expects
them to tell those lies and so now we
have a situation where people are
addicted to this stuff and they want
their manufactured outrage they want
their scapegoats they want their you
know lines like they used to get from
Tucker about immigrants make the country
dirtier and whatever else the case may
be and this is everywhere just the other
day I was at a Trader Joe's and there
was a young couple there maybe mid to
late 20s and uh the the guy it was a
heterosexual couple meaning there was a
man and a woman and the a man they were
this is so insane it sounds made up but
it's all too real I was looking for a
particular type of popsicle that my
girlfriend likes it's it's tangerine and
apparently it's seasonal so I was
looking and saying sir ma'am where is it
they didn't have it but in that same
freezer area
there's normally mochi mochi is
delicious absolutely delicious Mochi ice
cream and they were out of the green tea
Mochi ice cream
and a guy says to his girlfriend Joe
Biden screwed up the dairy supply chain
and that's why there's no effing Mochi
here and I said this has to be a I'm
sure this guy's kidding I'm sure this
guy is kidding and
I kind of looked over and he wasn't
kidding okay this is just a little
meaningless anecdote about the type of
completely unhinged uh scapegoating and
outrage that the Fox News audience wants
so a real problem for Fox News I'm sure
they will figure it out unless they end
up with billions more in settlements all
right let's now go to some stunning new
polling data which reveals that there
could be a brutal 2024 election cycle
coming for republicans and it is all
revealed thanks to a Fox News poll now I
want to remind people
there's no hypocrisy in saying Fox News
content is agit trash that should be
flushed down the toilet but we can look
at their polling Fox News polling is
fine it's relatively well rated and it's
it's generally pretty well done you know
Fox doesn't do the polling itself just
like CNN doesn't do its its own they
hire a polling firm okay check this out
and this could really be a preview of
what's coming uh Fox poll shows
Republicans in for a brutal 2024
election even Fox is admitting on air
that the policies it pushes aren't all
that popular with voters
they put up a poll and good for them for
doing it showing how popular certain
proposals to try to mitigate gun
violence are with the American people
and these are not shocking numbers to my
audience because we've been looking at
similar polling data for more than a
decade since the Sandy Hook shooting in
Connecticut background checks for guns
87 percent of Americans favor that and
again that means in all cases even
interpersonal sales all transactions
must have a background check enforce
existing gun laws 81 percent you've got
to be 21 to buy all guns that's not the
law in a lot of places right now 81
percent ban assault weapons 80 percent
favor that
and only 45 percent believe that more
citizens should be carrying guns this is
yet another issue on which the
right-wing media narrative has lost the
average American now obviously you go to
rural Northern Indiana where I've spent
some time and you ask people about these
things very few people will want
background checks for guns and they'll
mostly be against abortion now that's
the other question that this poll looked
at abortion should be 56 percent say
legal and 43 say illegal now when you
ask the question this way this is the
split 56-43
if you actually delve further into this
and you explain to people 99 of
abortions happen before I think it's 21
weeks and you explain more about the
reality of abortion you actually get
even more support for abortion just
should just flat out be legal before 21
weeks and yet there are states that have
passed abortion bans far earlier than
that so there's a few different things
here that I think are important to
consider this isn't really newsworthy in
the sense that on policy Republicans
have been losing for a long time in 2016
Trump eked out Hillary and it came down
to under a hundred thousand votes in
three states but then as the country
continued to move more to the left
it actually hurt Republicans in
elections the 2018 midterms were not
great for republicans in 2020 they lost
even more including the White House in
2022 it was going to be a red wave and
yet the Democratic majority in the
Senate actually grew it's interesting to
have a red wave where Democrats gain
seats in the Senate although they did
lose the house and this all may be
culminating in 2024. now I'm going to be
doing some interesting podcast
appearances coming up and one of the
things that I hope comes up is what's at
stake in 2024 because we have another
third of the Senate up for re-election
as we do every two years that's always
the case we have a presidential election
which may well be a rematch between Joe
Biden and Donald Trump and we will have
what I believe will be an inflection
point a fork in the road whatever
metaphor you want to use when it comes
to Mega trumpism magatrumpism has hurt
Republicans dramatically but it has hung
on thanks to the likes of Lauren bobert
Marjorie Taylor green and some others
maintaining their seats in the House and
uh elements of this in the Senate
lunatics like Josh Hawley and Ted Cruz
even though Trump insulted Cruz's wife
Cruz has become a big Trump isn't
trumpism acolyte Etc
Republicans will decide in 2024 are we
sticking with this direction
and potentially losing or are we
actually going to go in a different
direction altogether so a ton is up for
grabs in 2024. the Republican Party
has made politics more important for
young people with the issue of abortion
this was the problem we always knew
would happen if Roe v Wade were repealed
yes it would energize some people and
they will want and try to do even more
but at the same time you can no longer
raise money to try to overturn Roe v
Wade you have to deal with the
consequences of it being gone and the
Republican strategy has always been to
present themselves as an opposition to
some kind of evil something scary
abortion through Roe v Wade mattered
when Roe v Wade was a thing
you've got to keep the wedge issue to
keep voters scared so that they go out
and vote with you they won now that
issue has lots of its power now I know
that they've been saying well now we
need a federal ban on abortion it's fine
that Roe v Wade was overturned but now
we need to ban ban it outright federally
short-lived really unpopular idea it
also wouldn't pass because we've got a
Democratic Senate so now they're saying
well let's focus on trans anti-woke Etc
but the polling isn't looking great on
that either so increasingly they do need
to try to steal steal an election to win
one Trump tried it in 2020 and it didn't
work and we have to make sure it doesn't
work in 2024 either but a potential
bloodbath for Republicans coming up in
what is now just 18 months incredible
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
so we have another data point in our
building belief that Ron DeSantis simply
is not ready for prime time and would
completely fail if he did try to run
against Donald Trump in the Republican
primary which is not yet a foregone
conclusion we're still going to have to
wait and see whether DeSantis chooses to
get into this race a campaign for
DeSantis that is rapidly collapsing
before it even starts Ron DeSantis had a
complete and total meltdown when asked
about this former Guantanamo Bay
Detention Center detainee who has
claimed that DeSantis observed when he
was being tortured now DeSantis for a
long time has been saying no no no no no
I wasn't I wasn't in any position of
power at the time or whatever and
DeSantis just flips out here and again
you can tell he is not ready to be
confronted with tough questions by
journalists I don't think if this is how
he reacts to a simple question and gets
so heated and triggered I don't see how
he could possibly uh succeed on a debate
stay age with Donald Trump check this
out the latest DeSantis off the handle
no no not all that's BS and I'm totally
totally yeah
who said that
how would they know me okay think about
that do you honestly believe that's
credible so this is 22 2006. I'm a
junior officer do you honestly think
that they would have remembered me from
Adam of course not they're just trying
to get into the news because they know
people like you will consume it because
it fits your free ordained narrative
that you're trying to spend focus on the
facts
attacking the person asking the question
about newsworthy claims that have been
made is not going to get you a lot of
supporters in many circles including
Republican circles a better thing to do
would be to answer the question
substantively the problem is that in
2018 DeSantis also was asked about this
and he sure made it sound like he was
very much involved in what was going on
at Guantanamo Bay in a facility so it's
limited but some of the things they
would do they would do hunger strikes
and you actually had three detainees
that committed suicide with hunger
strike so everything at that time was
legal in nature one way or another so
the commander wants to know well how do
I combat this so one of the jobs of the
legal advisor would be like hey you
actually can force feed here's what you
can do here's kind of the rules of that
wow he certainly seems to know super
specifically the exact number of people
that were subjected to this that or the
other thing and says he was weighing in
with opinions about exactly what to do
that so during the feeding a group of
officers arrived with the interpreters
with the interrogators
they were behind the fence
and I saw one of them was Randy Santos
in a military uniform
and he was while I was screaming yelling
because I couldn't breathe of the insure
and was like I was bleeding because they
really insert the effect to you through
my nose
so I was like calling them asking and
that he was actually laughing looking at
the other officers and smiling all right
now could this guy be lying absolutely
absolutely but the totality of how
DeSantis is handling these questions
given his eagerness to show how
specifically he knew about every detail
of what was being done there do we
believe that on a place as small as
Guantanamo Bay DeSantis would have been
advising about exactly what to do and
yet never present at these events very
difficult to believe cut to now getting
angry at the reporter for even asking
the question he is not ready for prime
time I hope that he does run because
it's abundantly clear that his campaign
would be a complete and total
humiliating mess maybe he can mess up
Trump's campaign to some degree but as
far as a serious presidential candidate
DeSantis is truly lacking let's now go
to another guy who should have no
business anywhere near the presidency
Donald Trump Donald Trump kicked off his
New Hampshire wing of the presidential
campaign with a speech late last week in
that state in Manchester New Hampshire
it was one of the most pathetic speeches
I can recall from Trump doing the woe is
me stuff to a degree I've never seen
Trump's face as usual his right eye
almost completely swollen shut Trump
seeming agitated and irritated but
hilariously he kicked off the event
announcing this is a major announcement
he is no longer going to use the Crooked
nickname for Hillary Clinton he is now
going to call Joe Biden crooked Joe
Biden which is the super creative and
exciting but the crowd seem to like it
against crooked Hillary Clinton
but
today I'm going to do this and I think
this could
yesterday because this is going to be a
May or announcement are you ready
[Music]
I will be retiring the name crooked from
Hillary Clinton and her moniker
and I'm gonna give her a new name I
don't know like maybe lovely Hillary or
beautiful Hillary but I'm going to
retire
the name crooked so that we can use the
name for Joe Biden because he'll be
known from now on as crooked Joe Biden
just absolutely electrifying the crowd
and of course as you all know that'll
get six million more people health care
so that's really something that is
actionable and important for a
presidential candidate to be talking
about
and this was that was one of the better
parts of the speech I hate to tell you
and the New Hampshire crowd
particularly sycophantic uh Trump
bringing up Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-un and
talking about how great of a
relationship he had with the dictator
South Korea we take care of their
economy we take care of everything by
the way being more critical of South
Korea than North Korea here I think we
take care of the military they're right
next door to Kim Jong-un he and I have a
very good relationship people would say
it's not good to have a good relay yes
it's very good to have a good
relationship it really is
but he's not so happy with uh Biden
he says bad things about Biden but what
I really yeah Trump still seems to think
that when dictators like you it says
something good about you now of course
the truth is far more complicated than
that but this idea that we should be
concerned that Kim Jong-un doesn't like
Biden if it's true right uh no we should
have been concerned by the degree to
which Kim Jong-un felt he could roll
right over Trump and I actually recently
read uh the new Bradley hope book about
North Korea which I recommend to people
and it actually outlines a lot of the
ways in which the Trump foreign policy
towards North Korea to the extent that
there was foreign policy rather than
just Trump's ego running everything
um very much uh worth reading Bradley
Hope's new book about North Korea now at
another point during this speech Trump
uh quotes Lenin and refers to him as
Lenin and this is another one of these
things where we just don't really know
how Trump gets into this you know Lenin
Lenin did anyone ever hear of blood in
he said the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate has anyone
ever heard that's right Lennon Lenin as
they say
as they say in Russia I almost thought
Trump was going to be quoting some
lyrics from the great song Imagine
written of course by John lennine but he
didn't he was quoting Vladimir Lenin
there
um Trump seemingly justifying just not
debating in the Republican primary and
uh he talks about how Nixon and Reagan
and Bush didn't debate but of course you
know it was a completely different
situation in that they
there was not actually a primary in
those cases listen to this and this is
Trump starting to pre-lay the groundwork
to not participate in debates that might
not go well for him team as they go
prevents say bet on the opponent and
then they want to
do something under debates think of this
they want to debate they want to have I
have people at one half of one percent
one quarter of one percent one percent
three percent two percent four percent
seven percent and the Sanctus is very
low and crashing he's crashing and
burning don't forget when he came to me
he was at three percent
so he failed in his campaign he said sir
he endorsed him
which I could have done without but I
endorsed him and he went up a lot but he
went up and he won but when he kept
riveting stuff as you can tell pain for
a long time he failed and now he's
failing again because now he's getting a
chance to campaign without Trump to put
it mildly to put it mildly
but so these debates you know uh
Nixon and Reagan and
uh bush bush number one uh others
no they didn't debate in the primers now
why didn't they debate in the primaries
it was because they were sitting
presidents running for re-election of
course the difference is Trump is not
currently the president although maybe
he thinks he is maybe his followers
think that he is so there's an open
Republican primary that's just the
reality Trump then weirdly turns on one
of his earliest and strongest supporters
Senator Lindsey Graham who was recently
on TV crying because Trump needed money
um he calls Lindsey Graham a progressive
this is a really strange moment it's
called reciprocal reciprocal
reciprocal
so if India charges our companies a
hundred we charge their companies a
hundreds very simple and yet we have
people in Congress that say no I don't
think that's good anybody that says
that's no good very interesting Lindsey
Graham the progressive from South
Carolina and the crowd booze I thought
they liked Lindsay
no he's a progressor
but he's got some good things too okay
but Lindsey Graham I said to him Lindsay
you got to go along with this we were
all set to get it done you got to go
along with this he says so let me let me
get this straight if they charge us we
charge them the same thing he said it's
not his strength other things are his
strength he said so they charge us we
charge them the same thing right yeah
you got my vote
that's so easy all right so I guess
Lindsey Graham you know when I think of
your classic Progressive I of course
think immediately of Lindsey Graham
really strange moment Trump did that
disgusting anti-transgender
weightlifting routine and this really
really titillated the crowd probably the
most electrifying moment of the speech
should I do it
[Applause]
all right that's Trump's visibly
straining to lift uh weights which is
really one of the favorite things I mean
the crowd was pretty dead throughout so
that that uh wound them up a little bit
Trump did deal with policy yeah sort of
dealt with policy by saying he will put
in his travel ban again and he mentions
something about you saw that right but
of course it's like never clear what
he's talking about
and I will restore my travel ban to keep
radical Islamic terrorists out of our
country
you saw what happened four years four
years we went four years you saw that
right
we were very tough on that we don't want
our buildings blown up we don't want to
have problems to buy out of here all
right so um Trump
also took questions which was hilarious
because he didn't answer any of them
here's someone who asked him how will
you engage with Generation Z voters and
Trump just basically said oh we're
already doing it it's like oh I already
problem solved I guess thank you very
much God bless you my name is Christine
I'm
sure and
Eric and first Warriors like Caroline
Levitt right how do you plan how do you
plan to engage with Gen Z voters well I
think we're doing that and I tell you
what you would be shocked like Charlie
Kirk and others the job that they do
with their with their
youth it's a youth movement it really is
that's another movement you would be
shocked to see how popular we are on
college campuses much different than
what you read yeah well we we actually
have the election results from 2020 and
2022. uh they are not engaging with Gen
Z and in fact what's been going on with
abortion is probably only going to turn
off more gen Z voters so a ridiculous
speech but the crowd liked elements of
it so that gets us to our next question
who goes to a speech like this you might
be wondering
Trump has an event at 4 P.M on a
Thursday in New Hampshire
who goes to such a speech in the middle
of the work day on a Thursday in New
Hampshire well the great thing is we
have video of who goes there let's take
a look they actually interviewed on
right side broadcasting a young guy who
says that Trump inspired him to maybe
run for office one day at school they
tell him he's right he's a racist and
sexist but Trump uh has inspired this
kid or something like that look at this
the Future Leaders of America so what's
your plans you're the you're the
youngest one right now in Connecticut uh
where do you see yourself in time I
don't even know what that means I'm the
youngest one in Connecticut but no well
I got inspired by a man you know quite
well his name's Donald Trump
um and my goal someday is to get higher
up in politics I don't really know where
that's going to lead me but I keep the
same principles that he have never give
up never give in Never back down and as
a young conservative I've taken a lot of
heat especially in school I've been
called all the labels racist sexist I've
been yelled at by teachers because I
stood for the Pledge of Allegiance when
no one else would so I've kind of
learned that especially in Connecticut
which is a quite liberal State you got
to stand for what you believe in so I'd
like to maybe move up and run for office
when I'm done pursuing my education you
know get that degree under your belt and
hopefully maybe one day run for a
national office that's what you got to
do I love it let's just give a good
shout out on his outfit here I love the
uh
the kid is wearing
um a blue suit jacket that has white
stars on it it's sort of like a flag
version of a suit I guess I'm gonna move
on without any further commentary on
this one I think it's a minor and it's
just it always a little bit icky but
um I'll just say that that's really
really sad video they then interviewed
another individual who I guess is
legally an adult
and this guy says he's an atheist but he
also is a Christian conservative very
interesting so if I'm open and honest
I'm an atheist but I align more closely
with a Christian conservative worldview
and so
uh I pretty much support Christian
conservatism that horror that whole
moral compass and so that's what I stand
for yeah that I mean that's that's
really sad in that it is so mixed up and
jumbled I'm an atheist but the morality
of Christian conservatism strikes me as
correct therefore
I am going to support candidates who
actually think that I as an atheist
should have a subservient or secondary
status to them because they believe that
we should have a country that is overtly
Christian in terms of civil government
it's all really really whacked now
here's my favorite moment from this okay
there's an remember Ivermectin one of
these
cures that didn't cure nor prevent covid
that was being floated by many on the
right they have a new commercial on
right side broadcasting I guess the guy
who recommended Ivermectin to Trump has
some supplement that will ward off Spike
protein which they have there's almost
nothing true but the funniest part about
this is the the broadcaster on right
side broadcasting her diction is so
terrible and she barely even understands
what she's reading and at one point
refers to Ivermectin as ivervectin just
I can't imagine they sold any of these
pills based on this ad protein Spike
protein is the toxic substance that
attaches to your cells to allow mRNA to
enter worse both covid and the vaccine
function by using Spike proteins to
attach to your cells many of us have
become overloaded with excess Spike
protein from our surroundings over the
past three years and haven't made the
connection between not feeling 100 this
none of this is true I hope I want to
make really clear none of this is true
it's a grift on a Rift on a grift on a
grift then and Spike protein overload
this is a sad reality that we all have
to address fortunately there is help the
chief medical board at the wellness
company including Dr Peter Mccalla the
doctor that recommended ivervectin
ivervectin remember when we took
ivervectin guys and hydroxychloroquine
to president Trump back in 2020 as well
as renowned epidemic all right so
they're selling a pill that from the guy
who brought you ivervectin they have a
pill to get rid of Spike protein that
you might have absorbed from bananas in
the grocery store it's just the spike is
all in our environment which is really
really crazy then they got back to
interviewing people
they found a guy at the Trump rally who
remember the Trump rally was in
Manchester New Hampshire he came up from
New Jersey Because he believes Trump was
sent by God I think it's very important
to support Donald Trump if not our
nation goes down I believe he was sent
by God to preserve Abraham Lincoln's
promise that at the government of the
people of the by the people of the four
people will not perish but I think it's
rather ironic because I remember
probably nobody else knows this this
Armory in 1976 I was here when I was in
high school and this here's this is
where Ronald Reagan gave his speech
announcing that he was primarying
President Ford all right so a bit of a
history lesson and then the same guy
mentions that he would also be willing
to take a bullet for Trump and says a
lot of the people at the rally would my
support
my support of Donald Trump is unwavering
I would take a bullet for the man
seriously and a lot of us would and
we're gonna even if they wouldn't put
him on the ballot we'd write him in
there you go totally normal stuff and by
the way let's hope that it is a write-in
campaign that somehow Trump loses the
primary and these folks write them in it
would a guarantee that Donald Trump
loses all right last thing and then
we're going to move on some people at
this rally just a random lame rally
where Trump gave the same speech he
always gives with a little bit of
additional hysteria uh people camped out
overnight after driving up from Florida
I Was Born to Ride for 45 is here we
came I came from Florida 60th Trump
event we love Trump a lot of us come
across the country to come see the
greatest president ever Donald J Trump
I'm from Tennessee got here last night
flew in oh excuse me what you guys got
here was there anybody else in line or
oh yeah they set up the 10 over here and
stuff
four o'clock yesterday four o'clock
yesterday let's go in here real quickly
we heard you guys were here at four
o'clock yesterday setting up a tent
where are you from where you from Amanda
I'm from New York City the Bronx the
Bronx came all the way down here for
president Trump of course all right so
listen it's a cult we shouldn't for a
moment think that the cult has
diminished as we head into 24. what we
have to hope for and push for is that a
lot of them are just bored because
politics was just a shiny object and now
they moved on and that others will be
tied up with something else and just
won't be as engaged with the exact same
Trump message that he's been using for
six years now and that on turnout we end
up preventing Trump from getting back
into the Oval Office but for if if for a
second you believe the hardcore cultists
are any less interested let those
interviews be proof that that is very
very much not the case
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show Rudy
Giuliani appeared to admit how in the
1993 mayoral election in New York City
which he won he used what he calls a
trick to suppress the Hispanic vote
except for the life of me I can't
actually understand what the hell he's
talking about because undocumented
immigrants can't vote they can't
register to vote they're not citizens so
the back story on this election is that
Rudy Giuliani won the 1993 New York City
mayoral election by about fifty thousand
votes and he became the first Republican
elected mayor of New York City at that
point since John Lindsey in 1965. John
Lindsay in 65 was a republican then it
was a bunch of Democrats in New York
City as mayor and then we got Rudy
Giuliani in 1993. so we're going to take
a look at a clip Giuliani is on I guess
this is Steve bannon's show and he's
sitting between Steve Bannon and Kerry
Lake
and he explains the trick that they used
okay take a listen to this it created a
deterrent effect the fact that we did it
and John and I were talking about that
today the fact that we were doing it we
made it very public that we were doing
it and then I'll tell you one little
dirty trick okay A little dirty trick in
New York New York I'm so shy
how about this one so they went through
Eastern World which is all Hispanic and
they gave out they gave out they gave
out little cards and the card said if
you come to vote make sure you have your
green card because ins are picking up
illegals oh my gosh so the they spread
it off
after the election the Clinton uh civil
rights division investigated me I was on
vacation after the election and I get a
call from my lawyer Denny Young And he
says uh Rudy we got a uh the just
departments investigating us uh Janet
Reno's coming after us we violated civil
rights I said
Jenny you're a lawyer think about it
what civil rights do we violate they
don't have civil rights but we all we
did is prevent people who can't vote
from voting maybe we tricked them but
tricking is not a crime
oh and in those days we didn't have
crazy prosecutors nowadays they probably
prosecution for it even though it is and
that's the way we kept down the Hispanic
vote what a powerful story huh how Rudy
miraculously heroically and bravely
suppress the Hispanic vote in 1993. now
there's two stories is this a logical
strategy and did it actually happen so
the one issue with it as a strategy of
course is undocumented immigrants can't
vote they can't register to vote so I
guess the idea here was
even if you're so like
I actually don't understand whether this
is the thing where they wrongly believe
undocumented immigrants vote because
remember undocumented immigrants can't
even get on the voter rolls because only
citizens can vote do they wrongly
believe undocumented immigrants are
voting or is the idea that they wanted
to trick legal immigrants into thinking
if I don't bring documentation that I'm
here legally they might just because of
my appearance think I'm here illegally
and if I don't have my papers on me then
all of a sudden I'll get in trouble and
I won't be able to vote so that sounds
complicated so I'll just stay home like
it's actually hard to know exactly what
the idea is but it does seem as though
this was a thing I reviewed some
documents there is a document
um from what it from the Department of
Justice from contemporaneous to when
this was going on which says the
Department of Justice and the FBI are
conducting an investigation to determine
who prepared and posted these notices
and this refers to again you go back to
a 1993 Washington Post article it says
um Justice said to be probing New York
vote suppression Justice Department
officials are investigating complaints
of efforts to keep voting down and
democratic-leaning minority
neighborhoods in the New York City
mayoral election according to sources
involved black mayor David Dinkins
Democrat was defeated by Republican
Challenger Rudolph Giuliani in a in a
contest that produced perhaps the most
racially polarized voting pattern in the
city's history among the complaints are
the placing of signs on telephone poles
and walls in Latino areas warning quote
Federal authorities and immigration
officials will be at all election sites
immigration officials will be at
locations to arrest and Deport
undocumented illegal voters this is the
key line it is unclear how the signs
would intimidate naturalized U.S
citizens the only immigrants eligible to
vote so the article accurately
identifies you're going to intimidate
people who can't vote anyway now with
what is it 30 years of hindsight
We Now understand where this went 1993
Rudy did this in the New York City
mayoral 1994 this new wave of Gingrich
republicanism took over the House of
Representatives and it's been a path
from that to where we are today
Republicans that blame society's
problems on scapegoats immigrants from
Latin America being a very popular one
they've now shifted to well we'll blame
it on trans people marxists who don't
exist or whatever else the case may be
but it's all that same idea and you can
find it back then the
um he he's telling us that he did it
he's admitting to the entire thing and
it is wild and wacky stuff I am going to
admit to you this next story is a little
bit confusing
the story is about a Montana Republican
lawmaker who seemingly suggested during
a floor speech that she'd rather her
daughter kill herself than transition to
being a trans male now the confusing
part of this is we don't know whether
This Woman's daughter actually is trans
or has expressed uh symptoms of gender
dysphoria we we just don't know because
the clip is confusing this is state
representative from Montana Carrie
seekins Crow doesn't say her daughter is
trans but says her daughter is or was
suicidal for three years and that she
would rather her daughter be suicidal
than
um do the emotional manipulation that I
guess she considers claiming to feel as
though you're a different gender would
be in her mind it it's definitely
disgusting it's obviously uh the type of
thing someone who shouldn't be a parent
says but it is a little bit confusing
let's listen one of the big issues that
we have heard today and we've talked
about lately is that that without
surgery the risk of suicide goes way up
well I am one of those parents
who lived with a daughter who was
suicidal for three years
okay
someone once asked me wouldn't I just do
anything to help save her
and I really had to think the answer was
no and the answer was
no there you go I was not going to give
in to her emotional manipulation because
she was incapable of making those
decisions and I had to make those
decisions for her I was not going to let
her tear apart my family and I was not
going to let her tear apart me because I
had to be strong for I had to have a
vision for her life when she had none
was incapable of having none so she
doesn't straight up say my daughter
expressed that she's trans
but she said it was an emotional
manipulation
and if your child is suicidal and you
call it an emotional manipulation
whether they're trans or not
that's really something else and
remember these are the folks who want to
decide who should and shouldn't be
parenting children right these are the
same folks who then will say you know I
don't think a gay couple should adopt
but shouldn't or shouldn't be able to
you know uh work with a surrogate or
whatever these are the folks who want to
tell everybody else how you shouldn't
who should and shouldn't be allowed to
parent this is like Westboro Baptist
Church level stuff there is something
called narcissistic parenting and you
can Google this and read a lot about it
when a narcissist focuses their lack of
empathy and their delusions of grandeur
towards their child that's narcissistic
parenting and sometimes narcissistic
parents view their child as an extension
of themselves of themselves so therefore
they say well the child exists for my
needs and therefore I'm going to say
something like oh you're suicidal oh
you're saying that you're trans that's
an emotional manipulation I'm going to
decide for you this that the other thing
based on what I think is best for me
right now
whatever the full details of this story
are
a disgusting woman who no doubt claims
to have the Moral Majority
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Fox News host Mark Levin has been doing
a series of Sunday night interviews with
the failed former president Donald Trump
but last night's was so absurd that
Levin couldn't possibly save Trump when
Trump raises a conspiracy theory so
insane that it obviously doesn't make
any sense based on the facts but it is
such a verbal ink blot that you couldn't
possibly clean it up the topic was the
pandemic and Chinese tariffs and Trump's
claim is that China
made and released covid as punishment to
Trump and the United States of America
because Trump charged China so much
money in tariffs which ignores the fact
that Trump still doesn't understand how
tariffs work listen to this this is Mark
Levin can't possibly do anything with
this to save Trump China I was very from
I was probably the first one I said he
came from the lab in Wuhan I knew that
for one thing you saw body bags all over
the place around that lab you know there
were body bags all over
that area and nobody talks about it but
Levin is trying to stay as still as
possible to maybe blend into the
background and not even be visible in
Wuhan you had through satellite pictures
and other things you had pictures
body bags all over the place
and you could see little lines you know
from way up but they couldn't be
anything else but I said and I've said
right from the beginning it was the lab
in Wuhan they got out it got out of the
lab
I think it was incompetence I I really
believe it was incompetence more you
know people said I was charging China so
much money in tariffs and taxes that a
lot of people said they did it to get me
out but we did great in that election we
did understand what Trump is saying okay
think about how Bonkers this is the
tariffs that he was charging China
angered them so much that China made and
released covid mostly killing people in
other countries like remember most of
the deaths were not in the United States
in order to get Trump back
now there's a couple little problems
with this one is that's that's not how
terrorists work Trump still doesn't get
that when you put tariffs on Chinese
products imported to the United States
American companies pay the tariffs you
are charging American companies more
you're not charging China
so it makes no sense on principle but of
course if the 6.8 million official
coveted deaths only and I say only like
it's not a lot it's an insane number but
the point is proportionately of the 6.8
million covet deaths only 1.1 million
were in the United States so China to
get Trump back for tariffs that they
didn't actually pay did something to
kill 5.7 million people in other
countries including their own in order
to kill some people in the U.S many
after Trump left office as punishment
for Trump's tariffs which they didn't
pay this is so stunning stunningly
stupid that even Mark Levin says nothing
and is just motionless like a statue
Trump then brings up Abraham Lincoln
and says that he has actually been
treated worse than Abraham Lincoln
remember Abraham Lincoln was
assassinated say that Andrew Jackson was
the most vilified president it was his
wife died during this thing and they
said such horrible things and he had a
very tough presidency he was a very good
president he was a great General and a
good president
Abraham Lincoln they say was you know he
had a civil war going they say it all
right but uh Abraham Lincoln had was
just vilified he was
but now they say Trump got treated the
worst of all really because what they
did is they came up with phony stuff
Russia Russia Russia it was all hoaxes
uh the Mueller Witch Hunt which turned
out to be no collusion you know after
two and a half years no collusion I
could have told him that the first day
and they had the laptop they could have
figured that out because on the laptop
if you look at it you could have figured
that out easy but uh there's never been
anything despite that people is this the
most demented malignant narcissist
public figure of all time they say that
Trump was treated worse than Lincoln
Lincoln was shot in the head and killed
Trump was investigated for pretty
obvious wrongdoing and then Trump claims
that he sent former German Chancellor
Angela Merkel a white flag of surrender
to symbolize uh Germany I guess
surrendering to Russia I didn't allow
Germany to get away with what they were
doing I sent Angela Merkel a white flag
of surrender because I said when you
made the deal with Putin
you're getting 68 of your energy from
somebody that you've had numerous Wars
with world wars
I said so I'm going to give you the
White Flag this way you don't have to
look it up when you surrender to Russia
someday yeah it'd be like the U.S doing
business with Germany even though in the
past we were on opposing sides of a war
oh wait a second we do that all the time
what kind of an argument is that and if
you remember I made a speech at the
United Nations and the Russian delegate
that's when everybody laughed and
thought it was extremely funny when I
mentioned
that they shouldn't be doing it a year
later most of those guys were fired it
was actually the entire room that was
laughing at Trump because that speech
was so ridiculous lastly Trump takes
credit for the Olympics in South Korea
being a sellout it started off rough
remember that uh I was saying a little
rock and you're not going to get on and
I was saying little recommend and he was
saying uh I've got a red button on my
desk and I'm willing to use it and I say
I have a red button too and mine's
bigger and mine works and all sorts of
things it was very nasty and then all of
a sudden we get a phone call they want
to meet
and then I made the Olympics accessory
remember in South Korea they were having
the Olympics in nine months and nobody
was buying a ticket because they didn't
want to be have missiles shot at them
during the Olympic Opening Ceremonies
under understand what Trump is saying
he's saying the South Korean Olympics
would have been a failure had he not met
with North Korean dictator Kim Jong-un
because people would have been scared of
missile attacks during the Olympics in
South Korea
but thanks to Trump meeting with Kim
Jong-un where nothing was accomplished
by the way
that made the South Korean Olympics
popular this is a good time to mention I
mentioned it it mentioned it earlier in
the show Bradley hope has a new book
called The Rebel in the Kingdom it's not
about Trump uh it's actually about an
activist related to North Korea
fascinating book extremely well
researched but because of the timing of
when the book takes place there's a lot
in the book that explains Trump's total
failure when it comes to North Korea I
will admit I learned in the book that
some of Trump's instincts from the
deal-making business world
theoretically could have actually been
effective with Kim Jong-un they weren't
because Trump's execution was a disaster
and it really built up a more nuanced
understanding for me of trump dealing
with North Korea but if you really want
to understand again the book is not
mostly about it but the story will give
you an understanding of Trump's failures
with North Korea and Kim Jong-un get the
book The Rebel and the kingdom by
Bradley hope I just finished reading it
yesterday we have a voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P here's a
caller who doesn't like that we have
advertisers and is asking why we have
advertisers let's listen
I just think it takes away from the
overall message and it makes you achieve
um all right sorry
ciao all right ciao listen um so we have
advertisers because they generate
revenue for the show and that's why just
about any successful show has
advertisers
um I listen to you know Cal newport's
podcast I listen to podcasts from
Argentina I listen to you know well they
they all have advertisers and mostly
it's the same reason it's to generate
revenue for the show our our show does
have about four minutes of ads in it on
average
um it's a lot less than commercial you
know commercial TV might have 39 minutes
of content and 21 minutes of ads 17
minutes of ads sometimes we have a lot
less than that but the reason we have
advertisers is uh to fund the work that
we do now
um as I've said before we estimate
around one percent not even probably
more like three quarters of one percent
of our total audience
supports us with memberships on our
website around three quarters of one
percent if we were able to grow our
direct support from that three quarters
of one percent up to like two percent of
our audience supporting us directly then
we could do away with all of the
advertising on any platform on every
platform we're not there at this point
in time and so the reason that there are
advertisers is to generate revenue and I
think you'll find that that's relatively
uncontroversial we have such a great
bonus show for you today oh the bonus
show where you want to make money yes
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad why do we make money
on the bonus show to generate Revenue
okay more people are getting away with
murder in the sense that unsolved
killings have reached a record high
we're going to talk about it number two
federal prisons want inmates to pay
their victims before being allowed to
make phone calls or even buy shoes in
prison
what we will discuss and lastly there is
a sperm donor who has fathered 550
children who has been told it's time to
stop the reason why may surprise you
although it may not all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get a tidy little
discount I'll see you then and we'll
have a brand new show for you tomorrow